[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Kristen
is with us in Madison Wisconsin hi
Christen welcome to the Ramsey
Show hi Dave hi George thank you so much
for taking my call sure what's
up um so my husband and I were newly
married uh we just finished baby step
one this month uh we have
$45,000 in Consumer Debt in baby step 2
and as we're laying them out smallest
largest we also have some other pretty
big expenses that aren't necessarily
debt and we're just having a hard time
figuring out where they should St in our
snowball what are they we have um so we
have two vehicles one of them we own
outright one of them we have a loan for
$6,200 and the one that we have a loan
on is broken down um the rear
differential is completely seized up
it's not drivable it's going to be about
a $2,000 fix we're hoping to eventually
fix it and then sell it to get rid of it
um also we bought a house at the
beginning of this year and two weeks
after we closed on our house the pipes
in the bathroom burst and so that is
currently completely gutted we don't
have a shower uh sink um we or just in
that bathroom at all uh that's the only
bathroom we have in our house so we've
been showering at our mother-in-law's
house um we've been going over there to
do that for how long and then um for
about six months seven
months yeah she's two blocks away which
is great she's super close but it's def
pretty big there's nothing great about
this this sucks oh my gosh what a mess
and we Insurance wouldn't cover it um
well that's the other part I lost my job
recently So currently my husband is
working y need to write a country song
an hour we shower my mother-in-laws and
I lost my job yeah it's there's a lot
wow so what's he making
he's making $188 an hour right now doing
what uh he's a machine operator what
were you
making I was making uh 60k I was a
restaurant manager why'd you lose your
job um I was working in a restaurant um
I loved my job the hours were not great
I was working 60 to 70 hours a week
salary so I took a different position in
the same it was another restaurant
manager position and I moved over to
that it was going to be 45 hours a week
um and that would salary also so that
would allow me a little more time um but
uh a couple weeks into that they decided
that I was not a good fit um and they
let me go when was
that that was uh that was in June why
haven't you worked since
June well that's the other thing my
husband um
he uh had his driver's license suspended
and the car broke down um so we were
able why did he have his driver's
license suspended I can't believe
this it's been suspended for um for
quite a while he had to wait a couple
years um there was a period of time DUI
for the points yeah and then for the
points to fall off and so he can he's
eligible to get it reinstated now but it
is it's about $800 to pay all the fees
and for everything and then our
insurance would go up okay so your
excuse is you're a full-time driver for
an $18 an hour guy I'm calling bull
crap that was a dumb idea you make more
than he
makes yeah and so we were able to share
um we were working in the same town we
were driving yeah back when but now with
him being yeah yeah but now with you not
having a job you used driving him as an
excuse to not get a job so get another
job girl couldn't you drop him and then
go work and then pick him up or he gets
a ride there's a lot what you did
before yeah so we were um I can I'm
looking at getting I've been doing um
applying for jobs there were a couple I
got to the second interview um
restaurant manager positions and um you
know they ended up really not going
anywhere but now what I'm looking at is
um what would be wrong with mik working
60 hours a week
now what was wrong with it then you were
broke yeah
um it was mostly the schedule and
driving back and forth and not being
available to pick him up because I had
to stay late to solve a problem at work
and um so you lost $60,000 because he
didn't buy an
Uber yeah yeah you need you guys need to
you guys need to both be committed to 60
to 80 hours a week making $20 an hour
and you will solve a lot of these
problems you have in a heartbeat instead
you're living in a house that's not even
habitable because you don't even have a
toilet or a
shower and you haven't worked since June
you guys have got to go create some
money girl you went from 100K down to 36
and you got 45 in debt so if we get you
back to work problem your income the the
fact you guys don't make any money is
your problem and you don't work much
yeah
you both need he needs a new job he
needs a new job making 25 an hour and
two extra jobs making 20 an hour and you
need the 60 70 80 hour a week 60 to
880,000 would be the restaurant manager
job and buy them an Uber if you're stuck
at work I mean can you wait tables in
the meantime
yes um so that's what our next plan was
I can pay $125 to reinstate my CNA I
have to go take the the test but then I
would be able to get my CNA license back
and that's I'm sorry what is a CNA
license what is a CNA license CER
certified nurse
assistant and what would that
pay uh $25 an
hour 20 why would you want to do that
when you can make 60 as broke as you are
why don't you go get you some
money I I've been applying for
restaurant manager positions I had two
where I went to the second interview
second interview uh
process um I've applied for for more
than those but those are the ones where
I was um you guys need to sit down you
guys need to sit down and figure out the
way on the short term not what your
dream is but the thing you can do that
is moral and legal that allows you all
to work the most hours and make the most
money for about two years so you can get
your shower fixed and get your debt paid
off but you're not going to do it with
all these theories and all these limit
itations and you're finding all kinds of
reasons to not do this stuff um really
honestly 50 Grand solves your whole
life 50,000 bucks you could have made
that since June if he was working over
time and you were still working and so
you really have an
income your perception of work and your
perception of income on a temporary
basis needs to change that is your issue
because you guys need to BU you know $18
and I mean in a in a world where most
people are making 25 to 30 okay uh and
no you don't go get a CNA to make $25 an
hour when you have the income potential
of 60 to 80,000 at a restaurant and in
the meantime until you land that you go
get six jobs and you guys work your tail
ends off I'm fixing my freaking toilet
and my shower this is crazy y'all go
make make some money girl we want you to
win but you you you guys spend a lot of
your mental the in talking to you
there's a lot of mental gymnastics on
how why we can't create an income there
was a lot of them I mean you're like a a
worldclass gymnast well I know life has
happened to you I know it has but got
stuck in your head and you got this Loop
going and I'm trying to force you even
if you get mad at me I'm doing that
because I love you I'm trying to force
you to rethink your view on work well
every question that was well there's a
story behind I know but we at some point
we just have to put it down and do it
anyways and go to work anyways do the
job we don't want to do anyways yeah
exactly yeah you your $50,000 changes
your whole life you could go make 50 to
100,000 more than you made in the last
12 months in the next 12 months between
the two of you changing your view on
work that's how that's how fast your
life can turn around
and and the desperation that you feel
every day when you go to your
mother-in-laws to take a shower will go
away